hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
heute zu einem neuen video und zwar
wohlig von max das bin ich
max hat die tage ein video hochgeladen
was die erstes mal challenge heißt und
zwar dort sieben sachen in dem video
gemacht wir vorher so noch nie gemacht
hat
was am ende fünf youtube gezeigt genau
und da war unter anderem halt doch ich
bei und jetzt muss ich mich quasi hier
sieben sachen stellen in diesem video
die ich so noch nie auf youtube gezeigt
ab und allgemeine noch niedenstein zum
beispiel essen
er wird sieben sachen vorbereitet und
die erste sache die ich wirklich so noch
nie richtig gemacht habe ist eine
kissenschlacht ein sondern in dem jetzt
die kamera mit nach open comeback den
mann und macht mit kisten schleppen
ich fühle mich komplett drehen
ich habe einfach zu verbreiten und zwar
die ich noch nie gemacht habe brauche
ich dich mag es mal ganz kurz
nein nein
halo ist
da scheint es die kälte noch niemand die
kfw
mein geburtskirche
ich weiß nicht das komisch
als lukas weiss ganz genau und es wird
endlich jemanden an nachdem mit ihm
geredet habe die tat etwa eine minute
lang wenn ich ein video mit einem
anderen aufnehmen einfach nur in die
kamera
die nächste challenge ist dass ich 50
umdrehungen auf einem schreibtisch
drehstuhl mache
witze bei kurzen weg ins leere tische
mit 33 45 27 28 46 48
49 egal wie change next challenge
nächste die vierte challenge bestes ich
mit zwei paar schuhen gleichzeitig
rumlaufe also quasi es nicht anziehe
unter normale höhere schule reingehe
doch ich nehme einfach als grund basic
schuhe erstmal diese band zu müssen
gegen uns gehen
ich weiß es gelingt sollte 2000 jahre
später kamen sehr lange probiert es
hinzukriegen
aber es geht nicht und wenn man drei
schritte läuft dann fällt man ua aus den
maschen raus jetzt gesagt nicht einfach
rechts und links kommen muss schon
unterschiedliche farben anziehen
zufrieden
die fünfte scheinen sich heute machen
werde ist eine barbie kinderserie
freiwillig schauen
die wechsel challenge ist es sich über
kopf aus einer wasserflasche trinke
also ich sitze jetzt falls ihr auf der
couch im spiegel
max weidlich soll am besten hier schon
ansetzen und dann halt mit dem kopf hier
runter gehen kommt er drüber hinweg über
händel wein überhand über hinbringt
ranking trink trink trink trink trink
trink ein reh von extorre sagte das war
richtig dass es riecht komisch zu
schlucken weil es erst mal hoch muss
oder sehen kommen wir zur letzten
challenge und zwar werde ich in eine
zitrone reinbeißen allerdings nicht in
eine gewählte sondern einfach so in eine
zitrone
einfach so ein weißes nsg damit die
gewaschenen karriere denkt dass das so
gut geht aber die leute das was ihr vom
video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
denn die ganze zeit wurde von max ins
leben gerufen
komm ins leben alles klappt nicht
nominieren
die youtube youtube playlist ins kopien
20 lukas krieger emrah und sturm waffe
dass die diese challenge auch machen in
einem der nächsten videos musical über
30 wird er war eure aufgabe als
community ist es jetzt diese fünf leute
darauf aufmerksam machen unter ihrem
post youtube-videos et cetera damit sie
das irgendwie wird kriegen dass sie auch
diese ersten mal challenge machen wo die
quali sieben dinge machen müssen die sie
so noch nie irgendwas gemacht haben wenn
euch das gefallen lassen
da schreibt in die kommentare was ihr
gerne macht